hello everybody thanks for watching my
name is Alec Stettin I'm a senior chess
associate here at that's chess club and
scholastic center of st. Louis you may
be familiar with some of our YouTube
videos beginner breakdown chess Owens
explained and various Grandmaster
lessons and lectures that we put on
today we're gonna be beginning a new
segment where myself or another chess
club employee will be interviewing our
resident Grandmaster currently and until
March 11th our resin Grandmaster is
grandmaster of our region of Cobian bard
thanks again for joining us today
hi Alex glad to be here the first
question here let's get started when did
you start playing chess and how and who
taught you I started to play chess when
I was 5 years old and my father taught
me how to play well what about your
first conventional chess coach or
instructor my first coach when I was
about 5 or 6 years old was a gentleman
named GOG Excel gishian and he you know
he taught me some of the basics and so
what was his name again God Gothic
sarkeesian geeks against the end yes
you studied at the Petrosian school
chess when your child what what was it
like study in there it was very intense
and it was prestigious to be part of the
school it wasn't easy to get in because
he had to show some potential and talent
to be accepted actually as a student so
that's why I was happy when they
accepted me I had to play some game so
the coaches can watch and they like to
be active I gave my one and say okay
well we'll take him do you remember what
kind of game you play was it no I
remembered a game but I remember I won
the game when did you first know that
chess was gonna be a big passion in your
life wind it was there may be a
particular tournament or event that you
realized that going forward chess was
going to be a big thing probably when I
was about nine years old I just wondered
Armenian Junior Championship and
qualified to represent our me in a World
Youth Championship and I had a good
showing there as well
finishing in top ten and after a
tournament I realized that I want to
study more seriously and become a
grandmaster as soon as possible when did
you get your Grandmaster title how old
are you anything specific that you
remember
it yeah I got to my title just about a
week after my 19th birthday in Los
Angeles I won the tournament round-robin
tournament obtained my last norm and had
over 2500 PD ratings so it was just the
last requirement to become a grandmaster
so you uh you got your knives norm out
there on the west coast in LA and you
still live there currently right yeah is
leaving La right now I lived for two
years in Kansas as well so I like the
Midwest
I like the st. Louis I've been coming
here a lot for the past three years so
yeah yeah I spend half a year here I'm
very familiar with st. Louis with the
Chess Club with people who work here so
every time I come here it's it's a
pleasure again glad to hear it
I can think of one but are there any big
tournaments or events that you're
looking forward to competing in or
watching absolutely I'm looking forward
to compete in the US Championship
starting middle of April April 13
actually it's coming up soon so I need
to get to work and start studying
actually there's some very serious
opponents in that tournament so yeah
that's a very prestigious tournament
every elite players in the tournament so
this is definitely going to be the
strongest US Championship and it's gonna
be some very exciting games to watch you
know to see who will prevail in this
tournament to reiterate what var just
said the US Championships will be hosted
here at the same let's chess club as
they are every year if you can't make it
out to the club you can always follow
the action on US chess champ comm var
you're one of the most popular
grandmasters that we have in fact on our
YouTube channel STL chess club one of
your videos is the single most popular
video we have on our whole Channel can
you tell me a little bit about that
video yeah that video is actually it's
quite interesting it's very very popular
at almost half a million views already
and I talked about the beginning
beginners it's a kid's class for the
beginners chess I explained the ideas
how to open up with d4 and yeah just
I've had some other I have some other
very good videos out there but this one
in particular I guess the way I explain
it's very simple a lot of people when
they want to learn new openings they
watch it that's why it's more popular
but currently there are a lot more
videos that I'm recording I did a world
champion
lectures beginners some beginners videos
for the sunday kids class so many many
videos so if you go to the channel for
the Chess Club you will see all the
current videos that I'm recording and
they're uploaded to almost immediately
var what's one of your favorite games
that you've ever played in or analyzed
my favorite game that I analyzed I
played some interesting games but this
game in particular is the game between
Tigran Petrosian world champion versus
Mikhail Botvinnik another former former
world champion in a group fell defense
of the world champion match where
Petrosyan won the game beautifully
moving his game for me to all the way
through g8 an end game to getting a very
nice positional a victory so I really
liked that day Petrosyan a bond of a
couple a lot to learn from those two
guys absolutely
what is about the French defense that
you like so much the people that like
that watch you and follow your games
know that you're an accomplished French
player so what is about the French
defense that keeps you coming back to it
well that's the first opening that I was
topped when I started with Russian chess
school so I've been playing it for about
27 years and has some very it suits my
style I think and very quickly
understood I'd the ideas of the opening
where I should put my pieces and I had
some good results with it I want some
very important games I also lost some
important games as well so it's still
you know we're still learning every day
playing it but I really enjoy it and
been playing it for a very long time you
learned the French defense when you're
five years old I learned it like 10
months ago for part 2 in the interview
we want to give you folks watching an
opportunity to ask him your own
questions so please tweet us your
questions at si si es si es el again
that's at CCS CSL or leave your
questions at the bottom of the YouTube
page thanks again everybody for watching
and come join us for part two